[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'idée est de faire en sorte que les
gens des pays riches donnent leurs
livres afin que d'autres les achète une
partie des bénéfices profitent à ceux
qui n'ont pas accès aux livres à ou dans
l'axé
[Musique]
ça nous est un peu tombé dessus on avait
ces livres entre les mains et le marché
était prêt pour ce genre d'aventuré
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
e
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
notre idée est réforme ici et tout a
commencé lorsque nous revenions comme
chaque fin de semaine revendre nos
livres pour quelques dollars à la
librairie de la fac
le problème c'est qu'un bon cinquième
des livres ne sont pas repris ce sont
des livres que les professeurs ne
veulent pas réutiliser parce que les
cours ont changé par exemple alors on
s'est dit qu'il devait y avoir quelqu'un
dans le monde qui pourrait avoir besoin
de ces un étudiant ou une université
quelque part en afrique à qui on
pourrait en faire un don alors on a
décidé de donner une maison à ses livres
qu'il en avait plus et tout a commencé
ici tout a commencé sur ce comptoir on a
ouvert notre premier compte en banque
avec 300 $ chacun ça a été notre
investissement de départ pour fonder
notre société on allait d'école en école
dans toute la région dans l'indiana le
michigan et l'illinois
on disait bonjour on est là pour
récupérer les livres
la première fois on a pu récolter 2000
livres ce qui paraît ridicule
aujourd'hui à l'époque on a dû remplir
le coffre de ma voiture des dizaines de
fois ces deux mille livres qui nous
prendrait au maximum une heure de
travail aujourd'hui nous ont pris tout
l'été
deux étudiants qui veulent changer le
monde avec des livres en 2003 la
collecte est lancé dans les universités
du pays
les couloirs ce pas rapidement de
grandes boîtes en carton c'est dans ces
boîtes que la magie commence on met ces
boîtes dans les universités à travers
les états unis le canada et l'angleterre
les étudiants qui veulent se débarrasser
de leur livre donc allé déposer ici au
lieu de les jeter
deux fois par an on récupère des tonnes
de livres des milliers d'ouvragés dont
les étudiants ne savent plus quoi faire
et qu'ils sont heureux de donner
aujourd'hui c'est plus de cinq camions
par jour qui arrive depuis tous les
états unis pour déverser leur collecte
dans ce hangar 3 millions de livres le
plus grand stock de livres au monde
l'équivalent de quatre terrains de
football de barbara style à voltaire
tout ce qui se trouve dans ce hangar est
en vente à petits prix sur internet
aujourd'hui
better world book vont un livre toutes
les cinq secondes à travers le monde et
parmi eux des perles rares
[Musique]
notre meilleure vente ce ne fut pas un
livre mais un document ce n'était rien
de moins que le second exemplaire de la
déclaration d'indépendance
il avait la même dimension que
l'original on l'a vendu assez rapidement
pour seize mille dollars
et pour les livres les plus chers ils
sont gardés sous clé à l'abri dans une
chambre forte
voici la pièce où l'on met nos livres
les plus rares des livres qui valent
tous plus de 5000 $ là c'est plutôt vide
on en a vendu beaucoup récemment
christian une édition impressionnante et
très rares des oeuvres complètes de
shakespeare voici le premier volume
d'une édition limitée des oeuvres de
shakespeare
c'est le numéro 26 250 exemplaires
imprimés à l'ombre en 1853
il n'est pas dans le meilleur état mais
c'est un vrai trésor pour certains
derrière l'immense business l'idée de
xavier christopher est simple se servir
des bénéfices engrangés par les ventes
de ses livres pour aider à la création
d'écoles et de bibliothèques dans les
pays pauvres
ici seuls 25% des livres qui arrivent
sont revendus le reste est recyclé ou
tout simplement donner ce livre devait
coûter une centaine de dollars en 2002
quand il a été acheté
puis il ya eu une nouvelle édition alors
ce livre ne vaut plus rien sur le marché
on pense que c'est encore un très bon
livre et qu'il vaut mieux l'envoyer dans
une université africaine
il profitera à quelqu'un qui étudie la
finance la banque chaque année ils
paient l'acheminement de près de trente
mille livres par mois dans les
universités écoles africaines
nous ne faisons pas que la collecte de
livres que nous envoyons en afrique mais
en vendant des livres les bénéfices nous
aident à payer les frais de port pour
ouvrir des bibliothèques dans les pays
pauvres
ils permettent aussi de suivre une
scolarité et aux professeurs d'avoir les
fournitures nécessaires à leur travail
c'est donc un impact incroyable que les
livres que nous collectons ici on sur le
monde entier
en plus des dons de livres il finance
aussi différentes associations
éducatives pour aider des enfants
défavorisés en amérique
vous connaissez tous la famille ours qui
vit dans le grand arbre au bout du
chemin soleillé au coeur du pays des
ours livres offerts mais aussi donation
tous les ans ils font un don de 3
millions de dollars à ces associations
c'est plus qu'un cadeau que vous fait en
mettant les livres dans les boîtes
vous touchez l'esprit de ses enfants
dont les parents n'ont pas
nécessairement les moyens d'acheter des
livres
malheureusement dans notre société
actuelle certains parents ne lis pas de
livres à leur enfant en ouvrant la boîte
les enfants peuvent dire et les parents
ont regardé il ya des livres vous
pourriez peut-être mans lire 1 il y
alors de bonnes chances pour que les
parents s'impliquent plus dans la vie de
l'enfant
better world book a créé 270 emplois
dans une région très lourdement frappée
par la crise pour aller plus loin xavier
et chris ont décidé de mettre leurs
livres à la disposition des jeunes
souhaitant ouvrir des librairies pour
connais pas grand chose au commerce de
proximité
mais brad a voulu essayer et nous aussi
si cela peut aider les gens à lire plus
s'il n'y a pas de librairie dans un
quartier c'est comme s'il y avait un
grand vide
la plupart des librairies ferme aux
états unis on pense qu'avec une
meilleure stratégie commerciale qui
réunit la vente en ligne et la vente en
magasin
on doit pouvoir y arriver
[Musique]
chris et moi on a beaucoup joué au
billard pour imaginer notre boîte depuis
qu'on a lancé l'entreprise
je suis surpris de voir comment la
notion de business social s'est
développée auprès de milliers de
personnes aujourd'hui tu peux étudier le
business social à l'université tu peux
publier des articles sur le sujet il ya
même des gens qui investissent sur les
entrepreneurs sociaux
je pense que ça va se développer car
cela un écho direct sur les jeunes
générations
de plus en plus d'entreprises vont
apporter des idées neuves qui seront
profitables à toute la société
on doit se baser sur cette notion de
gagnant gagnant entre l'économie
l'écologie et les besoins de la société
[Musique]